>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESAN-ELECT
GEORGE SANTOS OF NEW YORK IS
ADMITTING TO LYING ABOUT HIS
BACKGROUND AND FALSIFYING KEY
PARTS OF HIS RESUME, BUT HE'S
INSISTING HE'S NOT A CRIMINAL
AND SAYS HE WILL TAKE HIS SEAT
IN THE NEXT CONGRESS, DESPITE
GROWING CALLS FOR HIS
RESIGNATION.
BUT AS CNN REPORTS, MANY
QUESTIONS REMAIN ABOUT THAT
HISTORY HE'S OWNING UP TO RIGHT
NOW.
>> Reporter: AN ADMISSION --
>> DID I EMBELLISH MY RESUME,
YES, I DID.
>> Reporter: AND AN APOLOGY.
>> AND I'M SORRY.
IT SHOULDN'T BE DONE.
>> Reporter: CONGRESSMAN-ELECT
GEORGE SANTOS FESSING UP TO
LYING ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
ABOUT PARTS OF HIS RESUME, AS HE
SEEKS TO MINIMIZE AND DEFEND HIS
LIES.
>> I APOLOGIZE, IF ANYBODY FEELS
HURT OR BETRAYED.
I WILL GAIN EVERYBODY'S TRUST
BACK BY JUST DELIVERING RESULTS
FOR THEM AND MAKING SURE THEY DO
NOT FORGET WHY THEY VOTED FOR ME
IN THE FIRST PLACE, WHICH WAS TO
GET STUFF DONE.
>> Reporter: SANTOS AS BOASTED
OF WORKING FOR INVESTMENT BACKS
CITIGROUP AND GOLDMAN SACHS.
HE NOW ADMITS HE DID NOT.
THE COMEMAN-ELECT CLAIMED HE
RECEIVED DEGREES FROM NYU AND
BARUCH COLLEGE.
HE NOW SAYS HE DID NOT.
BUT HE MAINTAINS HE'S NOT A
CRIMINAL, AND STILL INTENDS TO
SERVE IN CONGRESS.
>> I'M NOT RESIGNING.
I HAVE TO LEAVE CONGRESS, IT'S
GOING TO BE BY A PINK SLIP BY
THE VOTERS NOVEMBER OF 2024.
>> Reporter: AND THEN THERE ARE
THE QUESTIONS SURROUNDING HIS
ALLEGED JEWISH HERITAGE.
>> WE'RE NO STRANGER TO
PERSECUTION.
MY GRANDFATHER FLEEING UKRAINE
IN THE 1920s TO BELGIUM, THEN
FLEEING BELGIUM TO BRAZIL IN
1940.
>> Reporter: RECORDS ON JEWISH
REFUGEES AND INTERVIEWS WITH
MULTIPLE GENEALOGISTS.
SANTOS NOW SAYING HE NEVER
CLAIMED TO BE JEWISH.
>> I ALWAYS JOKE, I'M CATHOLIC,
BUT I'M ALSO N "ISH."
I GREW UP FULLY AWARE THAT MY
GRANDPARENTS WERE JEWISH.
>> Reporter: CNN LEARNING THAT
SANTOS DESCRIBED HIMSELF AS A
PROUD AMERICAN JEW IN A DOCUMENT
HE SHARED WITH PROM INNOCENT
JEWISH GROUPS.
SANTOS NOW DRAWING THE IRE OF
THE REPUBLICAN JEWISH COALITION,
WHO SAYS THEY WERE DECEIVED.
SANTOS WILL NO LONGER BE WELCOME
AT RJC EVENTS.
>> I'M NOT A FRAUD.
I'M NOT A CARTOON CHARACTER.
I'M NOT SOME MYTHICAL CREATURE
THAT WAS INVENTED.
I'M NOT RUSSIAN PUPPET.
>> Reporter: AND PHIL, WHILE
WE'RE NOT HEARING FROM
REPUBLICAN LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY, AT LEAST TWO
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN-ELECT WHO
WILL ALSO REPRESENT LONG ISLAND
HAVE VOICED CONCERN.
WITH ONE CALLING FOR AN
INVESTIGATION BY THE HOUSE
ETHICS COMMITTEE, AND IF
NECESSARY, LAW ENFORCEMENT, TOO.
WHILE CONGRESSMAN-ELECT ANTHONY
DEESPOSITO DESCRIBED THE
FABRICATIONS AS HURTFUL AND
IMPLORING HIM TO TELL THE TRUTH.
PHIL?
>> EVA, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WANT TO DISCUSS NOW.
I'M NOT PAUSING FOR EMPHASIS,
I'M PAUSING BECAUSE THE IDEA OF
HIM BEING A MYTHICAL CREATURE IS
KIND OF WHAT HE CREATED, TO SOME
DEGREE.
ALEX, HE ADMITS TO LYING, BUT
HIS DEFENSE IS THAT HE DID NOT
COMMIT ANY CRIMES.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT IS SUSTAINABLE
OVER TIME?
>> WELL, I MEAN, AS A LEGAL
MATTER, AS A PROCEDURAL MATTER
IN THE HOUSE, YEAH, IT PROBABLY
IS SUSTAINABLE THAT IF HE DIDN'T
COMMIT ANY TRIMS, HE PROBABLY
HAS A TWO-YEAR TERM AHEAD OF
HIM.
WE'VE SEEN NOTHING TO SUGGEST
THAT THEY WOULDN'T BE WILLING TO
SEAT HIM OR THEY WOULD BOOT HIM
OUT OF CONGRESS FOR BEING, YES,
A FRAUD, BUT IF THIS STARTS TO
BECOME A LEGAL INVESTIGATION,
THERE ARE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS PERSONAL FINANCES,
ABOUT HIS CAMPAIGN FINANCES.
IF THIS STARTS TO LOOK LIKE A
PUBLIC INTEGRITY ISSUE, THEN
YEAH, I THINK THAT COULD LOOK
SUBSTANTIALLY DIFFERENT, BUT
PHIL, I THINK THE REALLY
IMPORTANT CONTEXT FOR THIS IS,
THIS IS A TOUGH DISTRICT FOR
REPUBLICANS TO HOLD.
THEY TOOK IT THIS FALL IN A
LOCALIZED WAVE IN LONG ISLAND,
WHERE IF THEY HAD DOMINATED A
CARDBOARD CUTOUT OF A
REPUBLICAN, HE PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE WON THAT SEAT AND BOY THEY
WISH THEY NOMINATED THAT CUTOUT
NOW.
>> HE TALKED ABOUT A PINK SLIP
IN 2024.
KIND OF WANDERING HIS WAY RIGHT
INTO THAT.
>> HE'S AN UTTER FRAUD, PHIL.
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS SHOULD
TREAT HIM LIKE A PARIAH.
IN THE BEFORE TIMES, THEY WOULD
HAVE, BUT THEY WON'T NOW.
THIS REALLY NEEDS TO BE SAID.
THIS ISN'T SURPRISING.
I MEAN, IN A PARTY LED BY DONALD
TRUMP, WHO IN ESSENCE LIES
ALMOST EVERY TIME HE OPENS HIS
MOUTH, IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES AND
REPUBLICAN ELECTED OFFICIALS, I
MEAN, THEY LEARNED FROM HIM.
THEY LEARNED FROM HIM.
>> WELL, AND I THINK, TO SOME
DEGREE, THAT'S THE LESSON TO
TAKE AWAY.
DON'T EVER APOLOGIZE, DON'T
ADMIT ANYTHING IS WRONG AND KEEP
PUSHING FORWARD.
>> THIS IS THE TRUMP EFFECT.
YOU CAN DO PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING
AND WHAT DONALD TRUMP CAME IN,
HE STARTED, AS SOON AS HE BECAME
PRESIDENT, HE WAS DOING IT
BEFORE HE BECAME PRESIDENT, BUT
HE STARTED DOING ALL THESE
THINGS THAT WEREN'T AGAINST THE
LAW, BUT THEY WERE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE DIDN'T DO, RIGHT?
SO, IT STARTED TO BE THIS KIND
OF THING, WELL, IT'S NOT
ILLEGAL, YEAH, BUT IT'S NOT
REALLY ETHICAL OR OKAY OR
ACCEPTABLE.
AND IT WAS JUST, WELL, I'M GOING
TO DO IT AND WHO IS GOING TO
HOLD ME ACCOUNTABLE?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO MAKE OF
THIS GUY.
WHERE HE HAS LIED -- EVEN -- HE
CALLS THEM EMBELLISHMENTS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THAT WORD MEANS.
EMBELLISHMENT IS, LIKE, DRESSING
IT UP A LITTLE.
THESE ARE JUST LIES.
THEY'RE JUST FLAT-OUT LIES.
WHAT KIND OF PERSON JUST MAKES
UP ALL THESE THINGS -- ALSO THAT
ARE EASILY VERIFIABLE.
HE WAS GOING TO GET FOUND OUT.
>> THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT'S
HAPPENING HERE AND DONALD TRUMP
IS HE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THESE
THINGS WERE NOT TRUE.
HE'S JUST SAYING THAT HE SHOULD
STILL BE ALLOWED TO TAKE HIS
SEAT IN CONGRESS AND THAT HE
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING THAT WAS
CRIMINALLY WRONG, BUT GOING BACK
TO THE POINT THAT YOU WERE
MAKING ABOUT WHAT A DIFFICULTY
IT MIGHT BE FOR REPUBLICANS TO
WIN THIS SEAT AGAIN, THAT IS A
SEAT THAT HAD BEEN HELD BY
DEMOCRATS FOR ROUGHLY TEN YEARS
BEFORE REPUBLICANS FLIPPED IT IN
THE LAST ELECTION.
SO, IF A SPECIAL ELECTION WERE
TO BE HELD, THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT DEMOCRATS WOULD TAKE THAT
SEAT BACK.
NOW, THAT WOULDN'T CHANGE
WHETHER REPUBLICANS CONTROL THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES OR NOT,
BUT CERTAINLY IF YOU'RE KEVIN
McCARTHY AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE SITUATION, YOU'RE ALREADY
FACING DIFFICULTY WITH YOUR
MAJORITY, IT'S NOT HARD TO SEE
FROM THAT CIRCUMSTANCE FROM A
POLITICAL STANDPOINT.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY, PEOPLE
EMBELLISH THEIR RESUMES.
HE'S PORTRAYING THEM AS
EMBELLISHMENTS.
HE DIDN'T EXAGGERATE, LIKE, I
WAS A REALLY GOOD STUDENT OR
SOMETHING AT THIS SCHOOL.
LIKE, HE --
>> HE'S PUSHING BACK LIKE TRUMP
TAUGHT THEM HOW TO DO.
AND REMEMBER THE CONTEXT.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS STILL
LYING ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
MOST OF THE PARTY STILL BELIEVES
THAT LIE.
THIS IS JUST NOT SURPRISING.
>> CAN I ASK YOU -- WHAT I'M
STRUCK BY, LOOK, A LOT OF THIS
IS KIND OF FUNNY, MORE OF IT IS
COMPLETELY ABSURD.
THE COMMENTS AND CLEAR LIES
ABOUT HIS HERITAGE AND HIS
FAITH, I THINK, HAVE MUCH LONGER
RANGE HERE, PARTICULARLY INSIDE
THAT CAUCUS, YOU HAVE THE RJC,
OBVIOUSLY COMING OUT VERY
STRONGLY.
I WANT TO READ THE REPUBLICAN
CHAIR OF NEW YORK'S NASSAU
COUNTY, WHICH ENCOMPASSES PART
OF SANTOS' DISTRICT.
HE SAID, THE DAMAGE THAT HIS
LIES HAVE CAUSED ARE PROFOUND.
SANTOS TRIED TO EXPLAIN THIS BY
SAYING HE'S JEW-ISH.
THAT'S NOT FUNNY.
>> I SAY THIS AS A JEWISH
PERSON, IT'S A LITTLE BIT FUNNY,
RIGHT?
>> OKAY, I'LL GRANT YOU THAT.
>> BUT I'M NOT JEWISH, I'M
JEW-ISH, YOU CAN'T WRITE THIS.
BUT APPARENTLY SOMEBODY DID.
I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS --
HE SAID LAST WEEK, I'M GOING TO
HAVE MORE TO SAY ON THIS SOON,
AND I THINK A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
EXPECTED IT TO BE MORE LIKE, YOU
KNOW WHAT, YOU GOT ME, I MADE IT
ALL UP, THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
KIND OF TEARING OF THE SHIRT TO
EXPLAIN WHAT ON EARTH HAPPENED
HERE, BUT THE REASON, LOOK, EVA
EXPLAINED THIS IN HER REPORT,
THE REASON WHY YOU HAVE THESE
OTHER REPUBLICANS ON LONG ISLAND
SPEAKING OUT RIGHT NOW IS THAT
WHAT REPUBLICANS ACCOMPLISHED
THERE IN THIS ELECTION IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE IN A WORLD WHERE
THEY START TO BE SEEN AS THIS
PARTY THAT TRIVIALIZES THESE
LIES ABOUT JEWISH HERITAGE THAT
ARE VERY, VERY CLOSE TO HOME TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO LIVE UP AND
DOWN THAT STRETCH OF NEW YORK
STATE.
AND IF I WERE TO POINT TO ONE
PART OF THIS STORY, PART OF THE
REASON WHY HE COULD HANG ON
HERE, RIGHT, IS THAT THERE'S
NOTHING IN HERE THAT IS A SORT
OF RED CARD OFFENSE IN THE VEIN
OF JUST TOTALLY INDEFENSIBLE,
HOW COULD YOU POSSIBLY LET THIS
PERSON SERVE IN PUBLIC OFFICE --
YET.
BUT IF YOU'RE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AND YOU ARE TRYING TO MAKE
EVEN INCREMENTAL GAINS WITH
JEWISH VOTERS AND VOTERS WHO
KNOW JEWISH VOTERS, BOY, THIS IS
TOUGH STUFF TO TOLERATE.
>> AND THERE'S A HUGE
DIFFERENCE, AS YOU SAID BEFORE,
BETWEEN TALKING ABOUT YOUR
RESUME AND SAYING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
THAT IS WHEN IT BECOMES A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK -- WE
HAVE NOT HEARD FROM KEVIN
McCARTHY YET ABOUT THIS.
IT'S NOT OVERLY SURPRISING.
HE'S DEALING WITH A FOUR-SEAT
MAJORITY AND CAN'T AFFORD TO
LOSE PEOPLE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME, BUT TO ALEX'S POINT, THIS
IS A MAJORITY THAT WAS MADE BY
NEW YORK.
RIGHT?
MADE BY REPUBLICANS IN THE NEW
MAPS THAT WERE ABLE TO WIN SEATS
THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO IN A PRESIDENTIAL YEAR.
HOW COGNIZANT DO THEY HAVE TO BE
OF THAT FACT IN THIS?
>> I DON'T THINK YOU'LL HEAR
FROM McCARTHY UNTIL AFTER THE
FIGHT TO BECOME SPEAKER IS OVER,
BUT I AGREE WITH ALE